[MUSIC]
Please be seated.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Graduates, honored guests,
faculty staff, families, and friends,
welcome to the long awaited Class
of 2020 Graduation Ceremony.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> At the Stanford University
Graduate School of Business.
Two years ago, as you prepared for
graduation, we went online and
cancelled all in-person events.
Similar decisions were
made around the world,
later around that time, Queen Elizabeth
spoke to the British people.
Her theme as we confronted the growing
pandemic was perseverance.
She said, Well, we have faced challenges
before, this one is different.
We should take comfort that
while we may have more
still to endure, better days we'll return.
We will be with our friends again,
we will be with our families again,
we will meet again.
Today class of 2020 We meet again.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And
I am thrilled that nearly 400
of you are here to celebrate.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Let's hear it for
your perseverance, GSB class of 2020.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I'd like to take a moment to recognize
some of the people here
today GSB faculty and
staff played a pivotal role in
the experience of the class of 2020.
Could I ask GSB faculty and
staff to stand for a moment of thanks.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> We also are joined by families and
friends who have traveled to
celebrate this important occasion.
Let's turn around and take a moment to
recognize our families and friends.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> A typical graduation is a moment of
transition, we close the door on
the experience of being a student and
open a new one as graduates
launch into the world.
Precisely because graduates are so close
to being students, it is hard to fully
appreciate what has been learned and
what the experience has meant.
Today's ceremony is different,
rather than a transition,
let's conceive it as
a moment of inflection.
>> Have an opportunity to look
back on being a GSB student and
how that experience has
shaped your trajectory and
also to look out to the future.
The Danish philosopher
Soren Kierkegaard famously wrote
that life is understood backward and
lived forwards.
Class of 2020,
you are in a unique position
to appreciate what Kierkegaard meant.
As you sit here at graduation,
you have the benefit of
two years to look back and
consider what part of being
a student opened your
mind changed you influenced your choices.
I expect that many specifics have faded,
a has settled
on the details of accrual accounting,
simulation modeling,
how much you paid for
the furniture in your past down house.
Instead, moments of serendipity
take on larger meaning,
an illuminating common in a class,
in a memorable speaker,
a conversation that ignited a friendship.
I also hope that as a result
of your GSB experience,
you think more clearly about decision
making strategy organizations.
I hope you've built on the foundation
of leadership skills you've developed.
I hope the relationships you
formed have become stronger and
I hope returning this weekend provides
an opportunity to reflect on this.
When Kierkegaard wrote that life must
be lived forward, he meant that not
everything could be anticipated or
planned or understood in advance.
Sometimes you just have to make it up,
you learn that lesson in your
final quarter at the GSB.
You started nonprofits to
source medical supplies,
you organized dozens of virtual events
to maintain a sense of community.
You work to address racial inequality,
you're regenerative,
in the face of bad news and uncertainty,
you figured out how to create,
how to build, even had a contagiously
spread positivity We've watched
you carry that into your careers, if
today's graduation is an inflection point,
we should recognize that we are also
at an inflection point in the world.
We are gradually emerging
from two years of pandemic,
the world has changed and
we face urgent challenges.
My final message to you in June of 2020,
I quoted President Franklin Roosevelt,
who in the Great Depression
told the graduating class.
Yours is not the task of making
your way in the world but
the task of remaking the world,
which you will
find before you,
that still resonates with me.
As you renew your Stanford ties today and
relaunch,
remember that each of you has
the capacity not just to make your way.
Rise high,
build in a way that raises others set
yourselves the task of making
a better world around you.
Welcome back to Stanford and
congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Now it's my great pleasure to introduce
our speaker, Orlando Bravo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Orlando was born
in Puerto Rico- As a teenager, he became
a nationally ranked junior tennis player,
at one point even roomed with the future
world number one, Jim Courier.
He went to Brown University, and
after a short stint on Wall Street,
came to Stanford.
He earned both an MBA and
a JD from the Stanford Law School.
Orlando went on in finance and
private equity.
And in 2008, he founded Thoma Bravo,
with fellow GSB alum, Carl Toma.
Under Orlando's leadership,
Thoma Bravo has become a leading
software investment firm.
And a few years ago,
Forbes magazine called
Orlando Wall Street's best deal maker.
Orlando returned to Puerto Rico
after Hurricane Maria
in 2017 to lead humanitarian work.
Since then, the Bravo Family Foundation
has focused its efforts on creating
opportunities for
young adults in Puerto Rico.
Orlando was a trustee of Brown University
and a great supporter of the GSB,
and as you're about to see, his
brilliance and his energy are legendary.
Please join me in welcoming Orlando Bravo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you, thank you.
>> Yes.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> GSB class of 2020, let's go.
Seriously, and by the way,
that's something that I say
when I'm really fired up.
So remember that, because I'm going to
ask you to say it at the end, okay?
And I'll be brief, but I'm really so
excited for all of you.
You're here together, you
are the absolute best of your generation.
And you have come together
here to celebrate as
fellow members of our very
close GSB alumni family.
Now, I'm going to talk
to you from the heart,
because I know no other way to really
address you and really talk to you.
It is so meaningful for
me to be here with you today,
because Stanford has had such
a profound impact on my life.
The GSB is the place that gave me the
courage and the confidence to think big,
while at the same time encouraging
me to celebrate my past.
So here I am with an incredible
chance to speak with all of you, and
I want to thank Dean Levin for giving
me this just incredible opportunity.
I'm going to tell you a brief
story of how I got to Stanford.
And the purpose of my story is
that I think it best exemplifies
the culture here at the GSB
that all of you represent.
Exactly 30 years ago,
I got into Stanford, yes, I did.
And I also got into some, I'm just
going to say it, east coast school,
all right, at the same time.
Now, late in my decision making process,
I was able to get this job.
I didn't know I was going to get
this job offer, but I got it.
And I really wanted to do that for
a couple of years before
coming to business school.
So I first called the school on the east
coast to see how they would feel about me
deferring a couple of years.
And their answer was really clear,
absolutely not.
If you don't reply by this date,
you will lose your spot.
And if you would like to come years later,
maybe you should apply again.
With my hopes down,
I then called Stanford.
And on that call, the head of admissions
just happened to be in her office.
She picked up the line, and
I scrambled to start making my case.
And as I did, she stopped me,
she said, Orlando,
you can come to Stanford
whenever you want.
We will always have a place here for you.
Just give us about six months advance
notice and let us know when you're ready.
Wow, I will forever be grateful for
that call.
Stanford welcomed me with open arms,
and even before I set foot on campus,
Stanford was encouraging me
to do what I wanted to do and
it was opening big doors for me.
Now, I share this story because
it's a good one for me.
But the point of me sharing
that with you is on that call,
the head of admissions at
the time exemplified three key
traits from your culture,
our culture here at the GSB.
First, she was a real person.
She spoke to me like a real person.
She was genuine, she was authentic.
Two, she was relaxed.
She was casual.
And third,
she was focused on me being ready.
My goal today is to inspire
all of you to carry with you
throughout your journey these three
key cultural traits of the GSB.
Number one, be real,
number two, stay relaxed,
and number three,
be ready, be ready, okay?
Let's talk about being real for a second.
When I first came to the GSB,
I knew I was coming to the place with
the absolute best classmates and
the most impressive scholars,
but little did I know how much
fun this place would be, okay?
We found roommates and I lived with seven
of them and we became best friends.
By the way, they're here in the crowd
in very special seats after many years.
And we threw one party after the other.
I am sorry, but we did, okay?
We would go to Cabo.
And I believe it was my class
that started a tradition of
trying to rally as many people
as possible to go to Vegas.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Now,
I also understand that all of
you have upped your game, and
now the entire class goes to Vegas,
which proves one of my theories,
that the younger generation is
always better than the prior.
But anyway, within this,
Stanford combines an environment in
the GSB of the best of the best,
while at the same time,
a very fun and casual place.
And that in itself is such an important
lesson in leadership and in life.
Think about it, you can be the highest
performing individual while staying real,
while staying authentic,
while being yourself.
And when you do that,
your personal story will shine so
much better, and it will for sure make
you a much, much, much better leader.
Number two,
Sorry that I have to drink water,
I'm getting fired up about this.
Number two, I want you all to work
really hard in staying relaxed.
There's so much pressure now,
in being calm.
You're the best.
Why worry so much?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Really.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> When I graduated, From the GSB in 1998.
I got my dream job,
a dream job in private equity.
I've been trying to get into
the industry for a long time.
But then I proceeded to set
strict deadlines on my progress.
I put just incredible pressure on myself.
I worked so hard.
And three years later,
I had absolutely nothing to show for it,
except for
bad deals that we're all going to zero.
They really weren't which was
a disaster and I was about to be fired.
At the same time,
my first daughter was born.
I remember this like yesterday.
I'm there at the hospital.
And I'm thinking I forgot to buy diapers.
So I rushed over to the Marina Safeway.
And by the way for
all of you that live in San Francisco,
please don't go to
the Marina Safeway to buy diapers.
You go there to meet people.
It's an excellent environment for
that, but don't go there for that.
So I find myself in this, I guess,
diaper aisle, thinking, what did I do?
What just happened to me?
From the days of the GSB of thinking big,
of going to Vegas, with my
classmates to now about to get fired I was
completely unprepared to have a child and
fumbling through a diaper aisle
here at the Marina Safeway.
And then I promise you
something switched for me.
I started laughing.
I accepted the moment.
I let it go.
It all changed.
I relaxed, I calm down.
Two weeks later, I go back to work.
And my mentor, Carl Toma, also GSB alumni,
one of the greatest of all time,
he sits me down and said,
I'm going to give you a second chance.
I was calm I was relaxed,
I was at peace and that gave me clarity,
it gave me purpose and
allowed me to do my job with my own
personal style which resulted
in fewer bad decisions,
and better outcomes and
it was a better journey.
To do something really important and
to do something that is very personal so
it is for you to do you don't have to
go looking around for this event or
what this moment is it will come to you
for some of you that are already here.
Okay, the world will call upon you
to do something very important.
You're the best.
That means you will be
afforded a good journey, but
because you're the best,
you'll have a big responsibility and
you cannot opt-out,
out of that responsibility.
For me, an important moment came in 2017.
I was coming back from
a fundraising trip to Asia.
And as the flight was going,
Hurricane Maria hit Puerto Rico.
When I landed,
I knew things were really bad.
I cannot get in touch with family,
I cannot get in touch with all my friends
I get home and I'm glued to the TV,
listening to a lot of reports
on how aid was not coming to
the small towns right where I grew
up in because of logistical issues.
The only communication that I got
during that time was when my reporter
said there was a shelter
near where I grew up.
That had just 24 hours of food and
water left.
And that's when I knew I had my call.
At that moment that was a call for me
because if I didn't do anything about it,
no one would do anything about it.
Now, I didn't know anything,
about hurricane relief about
supply chains, I do software.
About logistics, I didn't have any
contacts in the government of Puerto Rico,
I didn't have any contacts with
community organizations in Puerto Rico,
I lived in San Francisco,
I had friends and family there.
But the GSB taught me to take a risk.
And to not be afraid of failure.
So we started a relief
operation GSB style.
It was entrepreneurial.
It was practical.
It was immediate.
It was results oriented.
And within roughly 10 hours of that,
we had communicated back to the reporter
to say we'll be there tomorrow.
We had filled up this plane with as
much food and water as we could get.
And we head off to Puerto Rico.
And when we landed, this man opened the
doors of the plane with fear in his eyes.
As if to say I can't
believe somebody's here.
The place was completely deserted.
And then I looked to my left and
on the road, there were three trucks.
They had made it.
We had made it.
And that's when I knew
I made the right call.
Now, that was my call,
you will get your own.
And I'm really grateful for the GSB
because it led me to think that this
incredible place didn't just train me
to be private equity professional.
It trained me for
bigger moments like this one.
I want to end by saying
that the GSB has given you
a foundation to solve
some really big problems.
Once again, you will be called upon
to do something really important and
to do something that is very personal so
it is for
you to do you don't have to go
looking around for this event or
what this moment is it will come to you
for some of you that are already here for
some others,
the moment will come a little sooner,
for some other the moment will come later.
But I promise you,
you will know exactly what that moment is,
and you will know exactly what to do.
And when that happens, you have to go all
in, and you have to give it all you have.
So, GSB class of 2020 I am
extremely proud of all of you.
You will accomplish incredible things,
much bigger than those of your mentors.
For now, remember and really remember,
be real, be relaxed and be ready.
And with that, I want you to repeat
it with me GSB class of 2020,
where we say, let's go one, two, three.
Let's go.
[CROSSTALK] Hey, there we go.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you so much, Orlando that
is a very tough act to follow.
Good afternoon, I am so
delighted that we have set this up so
that the friends and family can get the
full experience of the GSB by sitting in
the back with several empty rows.
Between them and the speaker.
That was a stroke of genius.
It is my pleasure as director of
the Stanford MSX program to present
the 2020 graduates who will receive
the degree of Master of Science and
Management It is so great to see
you all back here and thriving.
When we last saw you the pandemic
was just getting going.
And many of you faced incredible
challenges here at Stanford and
with your families at home.
You finish the program under
a cloud of uncertainty and we're so
proud of what you've all accomplished
in the intervening time.
The mission of the MSX program is to is
to provide experienced leaders Men and
women, who have spent at least
eight years in professional and
management roles,
the opportunity to prepare themselves, for
increasingly senior positions
in organizations they will lead.
MSx students participate in a full time,
year long course of academic study,
giving these students
an all too rare chance for
reflection and growth in the midst
of an already accomplished career.
On behalf of the administration
of the program and
the faculty who have taught them,
join me in wishing each of them
great fulfillment and success in
the next phase of their careers.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> In
honor of the service of former GSB Dean,
Robert Joss,
who was himself a student in this program,
the top 10% of the MSx class,
ranked by academic performance
are designated as Robert Joss scholars.
As we read the names of the graduates,
we will also announce if they have
achieved the distinction
of Robert Joss Scholar.
Margaret Hayes, Associate Dean of the MBA
and MSx Programs will now read our
graduates names,
while Dean Levin presents the diplomas.
>> Maya Dere.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jeremai G Kareem Adams.
>> Kingsley Afemikhe, Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eric Marquardt Aduho,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gregory Maurice Anwar Baro.
>> Nereeg Biani.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gonzalo Blanco Estatez.
>> Lauren Rachel Burrows.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Boyle.
>> Matthew William Brown.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel Carroll.
>> Elissa Chandler.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Elizabeth McPherson Chapman.
>> Sandy Chapman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lamia Lauren Daith,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Parthiban David.
>> Matthew Davis.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Anupriya Davide.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Charles Evislage.
>> J Finch.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Renato Flow.
>> Avishaq Garg, Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Garrison.
>> Kumar Gotham.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Oliver Hayward Young.
>> Thomas Kevin Higginbotham.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Neo-Vika Jane.
>> Pooje Jane.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Suwiji Qutari.
>> Chen Chen Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jamal Saad Magne, Robert Joss Scholar.
>> Liza Mosh Levin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Olga Maslikhova.
>> Travis Melvin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kayor Nithavala.
>> Thiago Morais.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Moyes.
>> Kaushik Nara Semin,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Whacar Nayar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Niki Panich.
>> Neewai Nina Cho.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Virgil Raghunathan.
>> Annete Ravel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Lee Rubinger.
>> Eva Solace Schlosser.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hannah Shivalava.
>> Stefan Johan Robert Bokfia,
Robert Joss Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Virkas Srivastava.
>> June Sudo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Yvonne Tamir.
>> Eneny Aloslip Sharp.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Stephen Tron Tron Voo.
>> Danieli VP Yanni.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alejandro Villalobos.
>> Lisa Ward.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Justin Wong.
>> Shia Ja.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Masahiro Yamamoto.
>> Takaomi Yukawa.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rick Jang.
>> Among the Robert L Joss Scholars,
one student's academic achievement
places them at the top of the MSx class,
This student is awarded the George C
Parker prize, named in honor of GSB
faculty and former program director,
George Parker who is here today.
George.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There he is.
>> The graduate receives a certificate,
a cash award, and their name will be
on a plaque displayed at the GSB.
The recipient of the George C Parker
prize is Abhishek Garg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Please, please, please stand.
>> Please,
there's Abhishek,
please stand and be recognized.
Great, thank you very much.
Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I am
now going to move on to the MBA class.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Distinguished guests, faculty staff,
family and friends, MBA class of 2020,
welcome back, we missed you.
You finished under extraordinary and
difficult conditions and
it's great to have this opportunity to
properly celebrate your accomplishments.
The MBA students gathered before us today
engaged in a transformational experience.
They acquired solid foundations
in general management and
pursued deeper study in
the areas of interest.
They engaged in personal growth and built
relationships that will last a lifetime.
They have helped the school and
the community in many ways.
While their experience here required
navigating the challenges of a global
pandemic that changed classes and
other activities in countless ways.
They persevered and formed bonds
that I expect will be stronger than
the MBA classes that came before them.
They're an impressive group and
are ready and
worthy to join the ranks
of our illustrious alumni.
Therefore, it is my great honor and
privilege to
present to you the Standford MBA
class of 2020.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I
hope your memories of the GSB have and
will continue to remain fresh and
that you will stay
involved with the school.
Our alumni played an important
role in your academic experience,
ranging from serving as judges
in the executive challenge,
to acting as mentors in
entrepreneurial courses.
I hope that you too will engage with
GSB's academic mission as alumni,
and give your time and
experience generously to future classes.
You will leave your own legacy and
play a part in bringing the GSB
experience to future generations as
other alumni have done before you.
On a somber note, I would like to
take a moment to remember your
classmate Erica Pincus,
who died last June.
In 2020, Erica earned her MBA from the GSB
and an MPA from Harvard's Kennedy School.
It is heartbreaking that she
is not here with us today.
We are grateful to be
joined by her parents and
her close GSB friends to honor her memory.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There is a picture of Emma in the
program and a seat among the graduates,
which is marked with a red ribbon
that would have been hers today.
Thank you for honoring her that way.
All of you here have undoubtedly
heard of Arjay Miller.
Arjay served in the US Air Force
during the Second World War, and
was later one of the so called Whiz Kids,
who revolutionized Ford Motor Company.
Arjay became president of Ford,
and then later the much
admired fourth dean of
the GSB from 1968 to 1978.
In honor of Dean Miller's service,
the top 10% of the class rank
by academic performance are designated
as RJ Miller's scholars.
As we read the names of the graduates, we
will also announce if they have received
the academic distinction
of Arjay Miller scholar.
In the case of joint degree students who
are working today, but not graduating,
we will identify those who are currently
in the top 10% of the class.
The late Dean Miller also founded
the certificate in public management and
social innovation program at the GSB.
The certificate program educates
leaders who understand societal issues,
design for and evaluate impact, and
understand the specificities of
the management of social organizations in
both the private and the public sectors.
Today's certificate graduates
take the spirit of our GSB motto,
change lives, change organizations,
change the world to its full potential.
We have 119 recipients
in the class of 2020.
Their names are listed in
your graduation program.
Graduation names will now
be read by Kirsten Moss,
Assistant Dean of MBA Admissions and
Financial Aid and
by Jamie shine, Assistant Dean
of the Career Management Center.
Graduates will receive their
diplomas from Dean Levin.
Kirsten and Jamie, would you please begin.
Abdul Abdi Rahman.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Samantha Abrams.
>> Pulkit Agarwal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Marissa-Bell Agosto.
>> Andrea Aguirez Ruiz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Modupe Aquinawano.
>> Elisa Albajia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Leila L Hassan.
>> Conica Sushil Alak.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eduardo Alvarez De Toledo Pinot.
>> Spencer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jack Armstrong.
>> Andreas Assad Kutner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Patrick Timothy Atwood.
>> Christopher Barnum.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Luciana Rossi Barrancos.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Hannah Barrett, Arjay Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mafalda.
>> Michelle Baumgardner.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lexi Blonut Rife.
>> Monica Beltran.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Amir Benveniste.
>> Ellery Burke.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> CJ Bernstein.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Barbara Schlafbeta.
>> Pooja Bhardwaj.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Otis Blem.
>> Edda Bora.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maya Butras.
>> Shelby Ann Brager.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> William James Brooke.
>> Timothy Francis Brown,
Arjay Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eduardo Civico Boisar.
>> Tommaso Cariati.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emily Carroll, Arjay Miller Scholar.
>> Matias Castillo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emily Nunez Cavness.
>> Ryan J Chan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mindy Chang.
>> Arnab Chatterjee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Josephine Chen.
>> Nicole Hong-Yu Chung.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jafael Claugh.
>> Peter Gallon Cohen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rebecca B Colby.
>> Dario Constantine.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caleb Crago.
>> Jorge Cueto.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caurl Dohera.
>> Arjay Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Madeline Dean.
>> Jaime Castillo Ojedo.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caroline Doing, Arjay Miller scholar.
>> Bennie Dear.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emilio Diaz Cotronaio.
>> Song Ding.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Taryn Disasnyaka.
>> Andrew Dodds.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ayodona Zaphaer.
>> Jane Dong.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Megan Diane Downey,
Arjay Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Adam Drux.
>> Robert Denlevy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Durkin.
>> Chinjes Jumanazarof.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Heather Michelle Eaton.
>> Maria Echeveri Gomez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicholas Elledge.
>> Sefa Ardon.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Izzy Ernst.
>> Tyler Ernst.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hans Fokejer.
>> Alexandra Farhat.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hernando Torldo Farias.
>> Lynn Farone.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> William Faulkner.
>> Jordan Alexander Phaco.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ian Andrew Lowelan Field.
>> Jill Fisher Bowen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eric Fuchs.
>> Khalil Fuller..
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sofia Garces.
>> Sebastian Garcia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Trevorski Garrett.
>> Toby Gerhart.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Luisa Catarina Gasnom.
>> Renata Geviola.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Matthew Gibsdean.
>> Ida Noelle Girma.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Adrienne Chi Gothuko.
>> Emily Gittens.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> George Matthew Seego, II.
>> Patricia Gochicoa Sanchez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Danny Gold.
>> Ashrar Goldberg.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maya Granite.
>> Khalil Grell.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Karishma Grover.
>> Javier Guinard.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Isaac Ashman Hails,
RJ Miller scholar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Stephanie Ham.
>> Ladd Hamrick.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tom Hanson.
>> Lowell Graham Hays.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tara Hill.
>> Jane Rebecca Henkel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Le Chem Ho.
>> Grace Horowitz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Wen Hao Edward Chum.
>> Lucia Wang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Gollum Emambayav.
>> Molly Inadomi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Namdi Iragbulem.
>> Karan Jagtiani.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hirsuta Normaal Jen.
>> Darren Jacqueline.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Jacobowsky.
>> Isabelle James.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Jane.
>> Akel Arvind Jerry Wallah,
RJ Miller Scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Derek Johnson.
>> Casey Jones.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Utashaw.
>> Alene Cabitenda.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nathaniel Kanefield
>> Aaron Cappy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jonathan Kaufman,
RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jacob Kemet, Rosenwell.
>> David Kavari, RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christine Kim.
>> J Kim.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Grace Kin.
>> Alexander Cannon Night.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ablogco CJ.
>> Alexander Cray.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Philip Craner.
>> Kelly Michelle Lakham.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Caitlin Jeanne Lang.
>> Carla Larin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ruth Lawinson.
>> Evan Lee.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kate Lee.
>> Timothy Shin Qing li,
RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Benjamin Leffe, RJ Miller scholar.
>> Daniel Levine.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ben Leveson.
>> Emily Winston Levy.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Anna Guadalupe Leyva.
>> Beixi Li.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maxine Kingt Lim.
>> Rich Lim.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shing Lynn,
RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cheryl Lou.
>> Eric Lou.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ran Lou.
>> Cory Longhurst, RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Olivia Lopez Velboa.
>> Megan W Liu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kevin Lubega.
>> Lorraine Siu Yunma
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Harry Mahadavan.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Julie Makelberg.
>> Yohanna Maldonado.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Colton Malkerson.
>> Tyler Maloney.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rohan Manchanda.
>> Dan Mandelbaum.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Imogen Mansfield.
>> Eleanor Hodgson Mensia.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sam Margo.
>> Hugo Martinez.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Daniel McDermott.
>> Yannick Meyer, RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sevda Mehmet.
>> Zubair Mamum.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Julia Milch.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Martha Mia cosca.
>> Haley Miller.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Kyle Mills.
>> Bradley John Mitchell.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Lucy Margaret Montgomery,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mikayla Ruth More.
>> Nene Moorhead.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hossam Mutlak
>> Rene Shantou Motley
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sara Moya.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Aditya Nagna
>> Tayhas Deepak Nafe.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Diana Hassan Musa Nazarv.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Heather When,
>> Roy Nicolay.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Temir Nesbitt,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nathan RJ Miller scholar
>> Tomac Navinsky.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Madison Obedio.
>> Hannah Leigh.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Chisholm Acapella.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Holadouyin Holadaddo.
>> Orher Olante Blanco
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Peter Olsen, RJ Miller scholar.
>> Valerie Osband.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Oved.
>> Carla Puccini.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Pesiwa Peggy Pen.
>> Ian Maya PunchChevra.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Peter Peres.
>> Judy Park
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sam Parker.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Thomas Robert paddock.
Yonten Paavola Nathan
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bushehr Pierre.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Andrew Pinelli.
>> Prussia Pin Nama Nanny.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Bruno Boleto.
>> Ross Pomerance.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Andrew Henry Powell.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bonner Campbell Price.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Alexander Prop.
>> Matthew Prusa.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Annie Chin.
>> Fabiola Queen Xanthos.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Vikram Rama Krishnan
>> Sangeet Renjen.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Carlton Perano Rawls.
>> Edward Redden.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Giulia Reiko Steen Stein.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Yun Fei Ren.
>> Danny Reyes.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Yama Resente.
>> Benjamin Grier Ryan.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Samuel Rieber.
>> Stephen Wrigley.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Felipe Rodriguez RJ Miller scholar.
>> Kiyum Rollin.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Gao Ron.
>> Gregory Rose
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> I 10 Rei Pro Shane.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andrew Rubinstein.
>> Victor Alan Rudo.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Robert Stonebrook Runco.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Marcus Rush.
>> Lindsey Zak Alerus.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Arts Hello Etea.
>> Luca Salah Moon Ich San
Martine RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Pedro Salgado.
>> Michael Monroe Saltzman.
>> [APPLAUSE].
>> Maxim Sup.
>> Alexander Sappington RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Lord Satterthwaite.
>> Taylor Savage.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alicia Sayer.
>> AJ Scarah Moochie.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Carlos Fernando Schekman.
>> David Blair Schmidt
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Robert Schneider.
>> Kimberly Schreiber.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nathaniel Seagal, RJ Miller Scholar.
>> Timofei Simenov.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Berto seminario.
>> Austin settle.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kavya Shankar.
>> Jess Simpson,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Angela Ray Cera woods,
>> R RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Joey Skevur Neck,
>> Elise Smith,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cleo Cecilia Spiro.
>> Charlie spokes, RJ Miller scholar.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Katarina or
Reeka Steagle Bruner, RJ Miller.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tara drooling.
>> Overall Sterovich Ross.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jack Straybell.
>> Carolyn Strawn.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Karen Sun.
>> Carl Lawrence Smutko.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sammy Telatin.
>> Allegra Tepper.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Katya Teran.
>> Natalia Choudry Talker.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sokhi Tomita
>> Gram Jason Topo
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Michael in Topo
>> Duke Tuan Tron.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Rodrigo Trevino Vargas.
>> Christina Troy Chino.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alan See, RJ Miller scholar..
>> Chloe Sang.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Selena Tyler.
>> Casey Wulan Hood,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Juan Antonio Valdez Guzman.
>> William Valori.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Moritz van Der Donk.
>> Igor Busey, Lucky.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> David Vasquez.
>> Sri Venkata Chien
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maria Andrea Variele Saints.
>> Claire Alexa Wallach.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> She Jenny Wang.
>> Eileen Marie Waris.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Zoe Weinberg.
>> Carly Wince.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Christopher Todd Williams,
RJ Miller Scholar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexis Sterling Wise.
>> Michael Wishart.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Emma Marian Wood
>> Sarin Sure.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Cowtar Yeish,
>> Madhu Yella Murthy, RJ Miller Scholar,
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bar your own RJ Miller scholar.
>> Bella Monya yu
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ryan Yura.
>> Vincent
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Diego Zavala.
>> Julia Zang
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Megan Elizabeth Zink.
>> Maximilian Zala, RJ Miller Scholar
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nominated and chosen by their peers,
the recipient of the Ernest C Arbuckle
award is a second year MBA student,
who by there active participation-
Initiative, leadership and
personal integrity, is judged as having
contributed most to the fulfillment of
the goals of the Stanford Graduate School
of Business in their actions,
both within school and society.
The recipient receives a cash prize,
and also has their name on
a plaque on display at the GSB.
We are delighted to have Susan Arbuckle,
the daughter of
Ernie Arbuckle with us today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
The MBA class
of 2020 Arbuckle Award winner
is Ryan please stand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I really enjoyed the procession I had
some great flashbacks to a trip to
Beijing with many of you a few years ago.
>> [APPLAUSE] That was great.
The Alexander Robert Check Student
Achievement Award in finance was
established to honor Professor Robert
Check outstanding contribution to
the teaching of finance at the GSB
from 1960, until his death in 1978.
The award is given to an MBA students
selected by the finance faculty for
outstanding achievement in their
finance courses, the recipient
receives the award and also has their
name on a plaque on display at the GSB.
The MBA class of 2020 recipient of the
robot check award is Timothy Francis Brown
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> There he is, congratulations.
>> And finally,
among the RJ Miller scholars,
one student's academic achievement
places them at the top of the class.
This student is designated as
the Henry Ford II scholar.
>> And receives,
along with the Miller Scholar Scroll,
a significant cash award and their
name on a plaque displayed at the GSB.
The MBA class of 2020
Henry Ford II Scholar is Nathaniel Segal.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [APPLAUSE] Honored guests, faculty,
staff, families and friends,
we have reached the conclusion
of our ceremony.
In a moment I'm going to ask
all of you to join us for
a reception just outside
the gates of Frost.
Class of 2020, will you please rise?
In the spirit of what
Orlando said earlier,
I'd like everyone to join me
in one final class of 2020.
Let's go.
One, two, three Class of 2020.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Congratulations class of 2020,
you may recess from the amphitheater.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [MUSIC]